time to spend my money Britt maimoni
ain't it fun it seems pendrick they're
my buddies I want to hang out with the
bunny cuz it's like the beat dropping
and I'm trying to get my little Wayne on
which Thursday how was that after you
listen to that yet oh I've heard the few
of the album many times album yeah
listen to it a few times you liked it I
I appreciate little Wayne because he can
go on like two minute things where he'll
be like in the sky and he'll do like I
like 20 different ways I think he's got
the first time I heard it I was like
album of the year I think it's good I
think it's good you're not like in love
with it the fact that he went at Elie
did you see that I was very understand
we didn't talk about that the fact that
Eli was like you know I don't really
listen to Lil Wayne like completely
throwaway comment and Lil Wayne was like
Eli how dare you disrespect me it's the
most quietly rivalry of the NFL season
well who would have picked Eli Manning
versus Lil Wayne right I can't wait
until Takashi 6 9 gets Eli in the booth
and they put together like a an attack
dish track towards a little we don't do
that down in the fifth Ward ok 9th word
so Sims yes start off here yes before we
get into the money that we made last
week or lost or lost before we get into
our picks all right how do you feel
right now about the process of picking
games where is your mindset
you're such a jerk I feel like I don't
have enough time to actually pick games
in my life ok like it's hard my life is
jam-packed right now you know this okay
I wanted to get your Excuse out of the
way like I'm good this week though I put
Preparation in yeah and what does that
mean I means I locked myself away and
got away from [ __ ] people like you
and I concentrate a little I wanted to
spruce you up I a positive to battle
that negative okay if you haven't seen
the tarik Owen bear Mitzvah yet you're
missing it out a lot of people of it
enjoying it I just got a text from a
number that I don't recognize
mmm are you ready yes hey Adam it's I an
eagle you and Kris have done some
terrific and funny he cursed [ __ ]
through the years this Tariq Owen video
may take the
KITT may take the cake or laka keep it
up but see you soon I didn't text me
yeah what's that about
well I text with a son Noah turned here
who's amazing right and I'm the Syracuse
mafia all right and you get a text yeah
let me do it right now so I can go hey I
just put you on blast on a pot camera
the man you okay well you're the man
Cuse you're the man go you're the man
tarik is a mensch Oh a they weave a
mirror Sims says thanks yeah hello
what's up Sims i love iron thanks man
what up your son is the man yeah he's
such a good dude this is a really good
podcast that's cool no but I mean like
that's top three pay play-by-play guy in
the world I have a degree with that yes
yeah definitely right I think so like if
I an eagle was there instead of Joe
tessitura
better broadcast but CBS ain't gonna let
him go now no but I agree with you there
right a percent yes like I know
filigrees okay we're doing too much
broadcasting time let's get to the bank
enjoy the bank all right guys last week
probably should have read that in case
you haven't heard let go you went you
had a pretty good week you went 25 ten
and five unfortunately those five losses
four of them were your bird Zim six and
nine last night so overall Sims you lost
$300 shitty hitter left go you made 140
bleacher bucks I'm ten and four and you
only made a hundred so the bank accounts
heading into nature it's Sims you are
sitting at negative one thousand four
hundred and sixty bleacher buck I know
what you get every pic right this week
you're back in it back into minus below
a thousand - you are at minus 350 which
upsets me because what I realized was
right if I bet a hundred on every game
last week out I would be above zero I
think I should start working for Vegas
that's it oh if you've got a hundred on
every game because my my wreck
good when I put more you got cocky all
right so we why do you have to work on
Vegas hockey oh there goes Josh writing
why should you have worked for Vegas
those rounders um my scores this week I
was all over the spreads okay I have
like five pushes oh and you're like you
know how I always say like this week I
sat down and I was like you know what
I'm not gonna like overanalyze I'm gonna
talk about the matchups in my brain yeah
yeah yeah what I like about him is just
feel real calm no I'm not feeling cocky
but I just said then I picked the scores
and then I then I type in my scores into
his crappy spreadsheet that he didn't
ever seem to send correctly in a weekly
basis it's all eyes I'm typing them in I
said damn I was all over oh yeah but my
day an eagle says give Chris my best
he's killing it on Saturdays with the
Notre Dame and he used that Notre Dame
emoji and in the am with a microphone
start picking games here are we Thursday
Night Football first matchup of the week
oh wait seriously though yeah I need
somebody to go get me Chipotle for the
ride out today okay it's probably gonna
be me but we'll figure what's left cozy
Eagle sims's Giants Thursday Night
Football spread for this game guys
Philadelphia minus three left go we'll
start with you first
by the way I had a thought I was having
conversation my friend Dan carson wentz
does not throw a good screen pass and i
think the reason is because he's too
honest and I think quarterbacks that are
more deceiving and are liars like
Donovan AB threw a great screen pass
because it's selling you're lying to the
defense right
I think Liars throw better screen passes
and Carson Wentz's to on let go your
breakdown that's the stuff that we my
friends talk of deep dive injuries
Darren Sproles out Haloti Ngata out
safety Corey Graham out Corey Clement is
playing just came down today
Lane Johnson is on the injury report
yeah I don't need to tell you
the Eagles without Lane Johnson of one
of the worst records in the NFL also
Holly pulley Vaati vitai backs up Jason
Peters and Lane Johnson very good the
scary thing is there's no guarantee
Jason Peters
play the entire game and I know it's
even scary when you think about the
Giants injuries Olivier Vernon is making
his season debut so here comes the past
Russia again though we don't know what
it's going to be the Giants though have
an injury problem right now at tight end
having Ingram's out ret Ellison is
questionable he didn't he was limited in
practice Tuesday and Wednesday it's a
valuable part of that patch Shermer
offense Here I am going to be going with
ya the Giants +3 I'm not [ __ ] let's go
ja and do that let's go and I am going
with $10 because I'm not putting
substantial money on this trends here is
why I am wrong Philadelphia 8 and 2 in
their last 10 straight up six and four
against the spread since when's his
rookie year this is how bad the Eagles
have been this is why I'm right there 2
& 6 against the spread is a road
favorite which is third worst in the NFL
and in their last seven regular season
games they're 1 in 6 against the spread
by the way when I said Philadelphia was
8 in two in their last 10 that's just
against the Giants they've owned this
rivalry yeah I see this being an
absolute dogfight yeah and I think it's
going to be close either way and I'm
getting a home team plus 3 this is a bet
I still think the Eagles might win this
game I think this is a dogfight what
really scares me - it's gonna be rainy
it's gonna be wet the Eagles don't have
anybody that if a guy falls down can go
the distance the Giants have two and a
half Sterling Shepherd is the half I
don't think anyone on the eagle like I
think Nelson I think that's a good thing
for the Eagles if it's rainy you do a
Kotel slower it's gonna make everybody
slower I thought they'd throw a screen
to him and he makes one guy missing the
toad out of the race yeah I just
it's fieldturf I am very afraid of Alain
Johnson less eagle yes but I think
Nelson Aguilar has a big game and I
think Carson Wentz has a big game that's
my breakdown yeah I mean I I'm with you
in this that I feel like it's going to
be an extremely close football game I
still think that the Philadelphia Eagles
are the better overall team in this
matchup and the Giants are home and the
Giants defense I am worried about the
lane Johnson thing certainly Giants are
home but the
Eagles just had to get on a bus like I
told you before we got here so it's
different travel yeah okay get in the
car at 4 o'clock they get on the bus at
4 o'clock they're at their hotel here in
the New York area by 5:45 and right so
it's a little different that way a
little easier um I've never heard that
mean I just think about little things
like that you know the Giants have shown
to be a little susceptible to the run I
do think that your Eagles team has
capabilities to run the football better
than they have Cory Clement back is big
for me but either way even with him
being back Doug Peterson just has to be
more patient with it there's more there
to be had in the run game on a weekly
basis and I do think they can take
something away from there the other side
of the ball hey I worry about one thing
Giants vers Eagles offense the defense
and it's kind of what you just talked
about I just worry about Jalen Mills in
some sort of situation with Odell or
sterling Shepherd and oh okay they blitz
and he runs a slant route and Jalen
misses the tackle but at 70 years are
who you all right and Jim Schwartz plus
Jalen Mills and our B equals guaranteed
one or two headaches every week I would
think this is the week that he finally
gets scared though and goes okay okay
it's one thing to leave him against
steel in man to man but I don't know
what boy something to do there that's a
that was like Chicago but it's one thing
to leave them but Odell is a different
animal to where I think I'm hoping they
were gonna put Sydney Jones outside
that's what I would like them to do yeah
but okay to get down to it your pick I
am picking the eagles to win the
football game twenty three to twenty and
since since there's one Eagles fan here
to push it's me so here you go I'm going
with the Eagles for $50 so twenty three
to twenty yes as you can see that you
nail the you know I'll nest let what
nailed last Thursday I could see I was
close yep
all right guys next game here did how
much 150 50 moving on to Sunday I got
some surprising we are you we got no
money on this game tonight so I'm okay
first game of the one o'clock slate on
Sunday here guys one of my favorite
games of the weekend
the Tuesday it is Tampa Bay Buccaneers
on the road facing the one in four
Atlanta Falcons I know the Falcons play
indoors 79 degrees in Atlanta
you guys want to factor the temperature
and seems we're gonna start with you
well okay I mean it's the Battle of the
crappy defenses okay and then it's too
explosive offenses I think I'll make
this simple I'm scared to death of both
defenses obviously both offenses have
huge advantages I think of the Atlanta
offense being a little bit more
well-rounded with their ability to run
the football I'm not worthless
you know I listen I'm just gonna make
this simple at the end of the day
Atlanta is at home and I just trust Matt
Ryan more than I do Jameis Winston who's
only had a half of football to this
point so I'm just gonna tell you there
I'm going $50 on the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers $50 but I picked the score to
be 34 31 such an Atlanta Tampa Bay
scrumping like that so yes the half a
point gives me the $50 bet to the buck
here are the injuries to Vontae Freeman
is not expected to play Grady Jared
scolder saying Devante know something
that's why we traded him in fantasy he's
he's one of his career where he's a
smaller running back taking a lot of
pound he's taking me he's taking the
side effects
Tevin Coleman though I'm not too worried
Grady Jarret also missed practice I
think that's a huge injury to Tampa is
coming off of a bot yeah Oh Jay Howard
still coming back from the sprained MCL
d'amore Dobson the right tackle limit in
practice but Bo Allen is back so they
get another big guy on a guy line yeah I
am going 100 dollars on Tampa Bay plus
three and a half and boy was I close to
go and more and I might lock this to be
honest here's why here's why I'm wrong
Atlanta three and OH in their last three
against Tampa Bay and against that Mike
Smith defense they're averaging thirty
three point seven points per game
quick note Ryan Fitzpatrick played in
two of those last three games another
reason I'm wrong Atlanta vs the NFC
South at home four and one straight up
and against the spread another reason
why I'm wrong Tampa in their last 12
road games two in ten but again
Fitzpatrick played a lot of those games
here's why I'm right tamp against the
spread against Atlanta the last six and
this includes Fitzpatrick n wins and
four and two against the spread
it's been closer than Vegas has thought
I love that 1/2 point that half point
makes me very first while it was against
the spring Atlanta gotcha
but here's the my main point yeah Jameis
Winston against the Falcons
I'm afraid typically a team's after a
bye but if there's one team that needed
a bye
it was the Buccaneer yeah get some guys
healthy get him in there and what we
solid a Jameis in the preseason probably
the best he's looked at a very long time
so I'm not gonna put too much on the
Bears in that second half Jameis Winston
the last three times Jameis has faced
Atlanta three games 841 yards 10
touchdowns one interception an average
quarterback rating of one hundred and
1.9 and that was with Deon Jones right
key on O'Neil and Grady Jared just in
case you want to know where those games
were - were in Tampa one was an Atlanta
sure but Adam was the one in Atlanta a
bad one it wasn't 23 a 32 281 yards four
touchdowns one interception and they won
that was towards the end of last year as
the first game of the year I was the
first one 31 to 24 you know what it's
the first game of Jameson ear yeah I
really like Tampa and I also go of
course people are gonna bother think
they're low right now
they looked awful in that last game
people were making fun of them then the
bye week
Atlanta's coming home and what did you
just say last week whoever loses that
game Atlanta Pittsburgh is done yeah
sometimes you come off a loss and you're
ready to go which i think is what's
gonna happen with Miami this week
sometimes you come off a loss and you're
like damn we're not that good I think
that's what happened yeah it could be I
know I thought about that too that a
part of me would really like that game
both of these teams are gonna be
disappointed with their last showing
regardless and I don't think the Falcons
are gonna go oh we're done yet so that's
kind of why I gave them the edge but I
don't feel good about them no and I also
think that Mike 100/100 Kendrick alright
guys next game on the one o'clock slate
here the three and one Carolina Panthers
on the road to visit Washington at 2:00
and 262 is the high in Washington on
Sunday partly cloudy spread in this game
is Washington - one sit left go we're
gonna start with no hurricane no
hurricane and Washington Oh
okay injuries Greg Olson is limited in
practice we're gonna see him back soon
which is pretty incredible
Cohen short did miss practice on
Wednesday and Ryan Khalil after he left
the game against the Giants is fine he
is playing Washington holy crap they're
banged up Adrian Peterson Chris Thompson
limited in practice Paul Richardson
Jameson Crowder Josh dachshund all miss
practice what's what's Thompson's issue
dachshund Thompson Thompson sorry
Thompson ribbon and knee well he just
got destroyed on that two point person
at the end of the game so Washington's
banged up man coming on a short week
yeah also Thomas Davis is back right he
is back this one I'm afraid because of
Vegas I am putting $100 on Carolina plus
one I couldn't believe that Carolina I
couldn't believe that Carolina was the
underdog and that's why I'm getting
scared it seems like a setup here's why
I'm wrong Washington is four and one at
home against the spread in their last
five games here's why I'm right Cam
Newton has never lost against you
against Washington for no straight up
for no against the spread as an underdog
in their last eight Carolina's five and
three straight up like when they're
underdogs they win more often than they
lose which is incredible and under Jay
Gruden Washington is 2 & 4 after they
play on Monday Night Football so he's
not great after a short week but what
scares me and the reason I'm not
pounding this and the reason I'm not
making it a lock is almost all of the
money currently in Vegas is going on
Carolina and the lines not changing so I
don't know what I don't know what's
happening in Vegas and sometimes when a
line looks really fishy to me I get
scared of it yeah and like that's what I
was surprised to see that too right like
I looked at that and ghost I love you
Carolina minus 3 right like they're
coming off a big win and and they look
like one of the better teams the NFL and
Washington got destroyed but there's
something about public embarrassment and
look Washington after they got
embarrassed to the Colts came back and
beat the Packers at home so there's a
little bit of a track record there it
scares me but I'm still putting a
hundred on Carolina because I think
they're the better team yeah
hey miss Davis is back right and my hope
was they weren't gonna have a letdown
because when Thomas Davis walks back
into the facility
he's like a centering force not that's
not a word
he's a centering force censuring that's
my last thing yeah uh this game scares
me it does scare me too um I'm with you
I think in the overall fact that I do
think the Panthers are the better
football team uh okay I'm just gonna get
right into mine and I'll give you my
reasons why I'm picking the Redskins to
win the game 2423
Wow it was a one pointer and the spread
and I went damn they're favored by a
point do see Washington what oh yeah I
know so I'm not gonna overreact to the
other night the defense did good things
until they had it committed a personal
foul on a third down sack and the guy
pushed him they got no ties with them
right and then they busted three
coverages I'm putting my faith that
Redskins are smart enough to go okay we
can fix these issues nor is the Carolina
attack which I value and like it's not
on the level of the New Orleans Saints I
just think the Redskins match up well
with them explain well I think with
Washington I mean Carolina's defense
they want to overpower you up front
they're not necessarily gonna play a ton
of man-to-man on the back end
you're not gonna overpower the Redskins
offensive line and also we've seen teams
that are very good at maintaining a
pocket and throwing quick short passes
having success against Carolina it's all
ask me that's what Alex Smith wants to
do any exactly right we saw and we saw
you lie do it last week too so that's
where that I saw that and I just said
man you know I had a clean pocket
throughout most of the game and because
they don't get up and play those
aggressive you know coverages and things
like that that slants and under routes
and things like that are there to be had
I got to think the course they're gonna
be extremely pissed off with their
performance is one of the worst
performances of the season by any to by
any team and and then I flip it over and
you know why I like this Carolina this
Carolina offense and what they do I
still there their run game is pretty
legit but this this spread skins defense
is good and I worry about Carolina's
tackles and pass protection still you
know the Giants couldn't expose it
because they don't have a great pass
rusher
I think the Redskins can you know I
think Carrigan Preston Smith Ryan
Anderson there's enough there to at
least cause a few issues every now and
then and I'm going to put in my faith in
a Greg Mineski that he will get things
right on the back end and the secondary
and they went a motivated really closely
obligating $50 on the skins yeah I guess
the reason that I'm feeling a little bit
more confident now I think about it but
the panthers is just the Giants though
have se Kwan who can take something and
make more of it and Odell that can take
something make more of it and they did
get a touchdown off of a wide receiver
pass the Washington doesn't have any of
those like that right and and Jordan
reason thing is to be a big deal huge
and Jordan Reed look was a non-factor so
that's my issue
yeah I hear you so you went fifty on
Washington Dean on Washington yeah but
that's why that game scares me cuz
Washington is a sound team yeah Carolina
waits for you to make a mistake to pound
right and I haven't seen we haven't seen
mistakes like the Redskins didn't
coverage all year except those Josh
Norman after being embarrassed and
pulled against his former team yeah
attack him yeah there he's gonna be on
his a game I'd like to see DJ more lined
up one-on-one then yeah other thing with
that game I need to see another game of
how they're gonna use Curtis Samuel and
DJ more before I jump on to go it's grow
it look good yeah yeah I mean if Curtis
Samuel can do what he did geez oh man
alright guys we're going across the pond
here for our next I'm not done to London
the two and three Seattle Seahawks at
Wembley Stadium taking on the one in
four Oakland Raiders spread in this game
Seattle - three Sims we'll start with
you okay um how do I want to start this
alright so if I go with Seattle's
Seattle's offense you already go
injuries first like that
KJ Wright is gonna be out it looks like
regime green missed Wednesday's practice
again this is gonna be tough for us
because everyone's gonna know the real
injuries because if you're injured
you're not making the trip so everyone's
gonna know Friday or Saturday like
Colette chioce Emily all of a sudden
suddenly on their missed Wednesday's
practice if he doesn't travel yeah
[ __ ] big right uh and Carl's Joseph is
back okay so that's the injury okay yeah
that's a big deal assembly I mean
Feliciano is not as
good as assembly in the interior part of
that deadline either way all right I
guess I would break the game down this
way the Oakland Raiders defense it's not
good
we know that okay there's a lot of
issues there they don't have a pass rush
for one that's one issue and I'm gonna
just make sure and they can't stop the
run and I don't know if they're the last
but they're towards the bottom of
football one thing I know and we talked
about it a little on our Wednesday power
30 a podcast is the Seattle can run the
football this is not just a fluke they
have it going and they have the right
personnel to go along with what they
want to do on the line so I think
they're gonna be able to run the
football yeah okay that the passing
attack for the Seattle Seahawks is not
like wowing jaw-dropping but they're
capable of being aggressive and making
big plays and we saw that last week
against the Rams we've seen it really
whenever they had to have kind of step
on the gas they've been able to do that
throughout the year Seahawks shut down
the Bears when they were trying to get
back into that game exactly right so
Dallas right right so and those are good
defenses biggest thing is I do think
Russell Wilson's gonna be happy able to
have his way one because there's not
great cover corners on the Raiders and
two what I always go back to with guys
like Russell Wilson and Aaron Rodgers
when you don't have anybody like
freakishly good on your D line that's
athletic I just think it's a game where
he's gonna be able to scramble around
and do whatever he wants at times
whenever they need a big play now the
other side of it
the Seattle Seahawks defense is not good
either and don't be fooled by their rank
or whatever they are they've only played
in my eyes like one legit offense so far
that was the Rams and they scored 33
points and they got lucky to get an
interception at the one-yard line and
had a few other things that break broke
their way I do think the Raiders are
gonna be able to move the football the
Raider is big dicks biggest deal is can
they score touchdowns can they score
points did I say something plays a big
dick oh I did it's okay because he'll
yeah okay I promise you I wasn't trying
to say that if I did so I think you're
that the end of the day I am going with
the team that I just trust a little bit
more I'm pitting $50 on the Seattle
Seahawks
but once again I have put I have picked
a push and I picked them to win 27 to 24
mm-hmm
but I'm going with I'm going with the
team that I what's the over/under that
can stand by a Ghost Rider the reason I
ask is because in London if you guys
want to start your days off great I know
is this one of those morning one o'clock
game on the East Coast it's a one it's
it's six o'clock give me that time give
me that in ten o'clock I love that I
know what is it Josh I'm looking it up
okay
because Fievel s six games in London
have hit the over which is so this is
gonna be a high-scoring game and this
fits the profile of it 48 48 take the
over yeah hundred percent yes I'm 56
percent of the public is on the over
yeah well the over usually gets bet more
because who's a loser and that's the
under weirdos I am putting usually
exactly I am putting a hundred and forty
five dollars on the Seattle Seahawks 145
I am here's the deal in all of the games
played in London the favorite is 15 five
and one against the spread thirteen and
eight last five years after a loss
Seattle is sixteen nine and one against
the spread in their last 20 games
against the NFC Oakland is 5 and 15 5
and 15 against the NFC now Seattle's
never played in London before right
Oakland has in 2014 a night that does
matter to me because I want to see if a
lot of guys made the trip sure Derek
Carr got hurt in that game and the only
other player that's currently on the
Raiders that made the trip Gabe Jackson
he's the only guy that played so there's
not a lot of crossover right but then I
can i sat down and went well what's
gonna be big they're out there in
Wembley special teams Sebastian
Janikowski revenge game I picked him up
on my fantasy league I'm seeing four or
five field goals from Sebastian I think
he's just gonna hammer that home you
better hope he didn't go to the pub too
many times it's also a Marshawn Lynch
revenge game
yeah I think that Seattle is a more
buttoned up franchise and I think when
you're travelling across to London all
of those things matter if the Raiders
don't have the money to pay Khalil Mack
probably staying at Nakano Lodge in
London whereas Seattle is ready to go
Michael Dixon's gonna be in his soccer
playing routes he's gonna be putting all
over the field and at the end of the day
I just thought its Russell Wilson
against the Raiders defense with no pass
room yes
Russell Wilson with time yeah haven't
even seen it yeah right I mean you could
talk about Seattle not having played in
offense but think about the defense's
that Seattle's faced von Miller I know
you're right Allison right the LA Rams
yes this is gonna feel like a vacation
you're right and I see Tyler Lockett
getting a few opportunities deep because
the Raiders always have a
miscommunication in the back always
Seattle is pound and then take a shot
yeah that's like the best way to beat
the Raiders pound and then take a shot I
liked Seattle and I liked them winning
by like 17 yeah good for you all right
guys next I wanted to go Seattle I did
London scared me that's really yeah but
you know what London used to scare me
and then it was the better team
steamrolls in London you know or
Jacksonville because Jacksonville's
could made that trip so many times like
when the just heads up when the Eagles
play Jacksonville in London I'm picking
Jacksonville just so everybody knows you
pick against the Eagles every week yes
sometimes next game here on the one
o'clock slate guys the Indianapolis
Colts visiting the New York Jets we're
gonna start this game off by returning
left goes $20 bill thank left go here
you go have you been to the ATM yet got
your cash do you have a 20 on you when
you bet against left goal just to remind
everyone on the week five betting Joe I
have two singles you want to no I don't
want your two singles okay all we have
to wait till I put it on my dab left go
picked the Jets - won last week against
the Broncos Sims pick Denver and they
put $20 of real money on it first spread
in this game is Jets - two and a half
Chris you're up first here are the
injuries yes 11 Colts missed practice on
Wednesday T Y Hilton and Jack Doyle are
already out Ebru on is falling apart his
injuries are shin quad ankle and knee so
pretty much anything below the navel
Darius Leonard ankle should play you
expect it to play that's good
two guys that are except practiced in
full Costanzo the tackle and Marlon Mac
haven't seen those guys in about two or
three weeks seven Jets miss practice
Isaiah Crowell is expected to play
Tremaine Johnson has a quad Buster
screen had a concussion though they are
truly questionable right so that's two
guys in the secondary where are you
going
okay so very even matchup it really is I
guess I would start here if I'm gonna
talk about the Colts offense the Colts
offense is one-dimensional to me which i
think is scary against Todd Bowles
defense Todd Bowles gets in trouble when
he tries to defend the run and he
worries about I have to stop the run and
then he become become susceptible to the
pass game and that scares me a little
bit I feel like that's what happened in
the Browns game it's what happened in
the Jaguars game it was oh I gotta stop
these offensive lines and that Baker may
feel the bortles kind of tore them apart
with some easy passes some good passes
either way so I always worry about when
it seems one-dimensional against Todd
Bowles Andrew Luck we know he's capable
of making magic with T Y Hilton I know
he's done without T Y Hilda nor Eric
Ebron he's still gonna be able to keep
this game close
I do trust that now if I flip it over to
the other side you know the Colts
defense they play hard they're sound
they don't have great man-to-man cover
corner 'he's on the outside and i think
they're going to have a little some
issues with stopping the Jets run game I
think the Jets have kind of found their
niche in the run game to a degree they
like Seattle have some big hulking
offensive linemen and a pass game that's
not special to me but I think it's got
chances in this matchup against the
Indianapolis Colts this game to me is a
very flip the coin type of football game
and I am going to take just want to make
sure I got this right I am taking the
Jets to win this football game 19 to 16
how much money that's recovery dollars
yes
$50 all right I'd like to comment that
Sims has only bet two hundred and fifty
dollars thus far which left go your
breakdown okay my breakdown I am going
to be putting $100 on the Colts plus two
and a half here's why I'm wrong who calm
down I know it's a cute little horsey
calm down whoa thank you for listening
the Jets are the NFL's best team
covering at home since last year Wow
nine and two against the spread six and
five straight up okay I'm we're an
underdog in a lot of games last year
yeah here's why I'm right Colts are
three and one against the spread in
their last four away games that was
Washington the one loss was the Patriots
and they covered against the Eagles be
covered against the Eagles right last
three games
I wouldn't added this up myself yeah I
if I'm betting this game and you want to
bet like in real time
take jets in the first half Colts in the
second Colts have scored 20 points in
the last three games in the first half
51 in the second half Jets defense this
year has faced Case Keenum Blake bortles
and a tie rod Baker combination their
last three this is by far the best
quarterback that they face yes the Colts
are coming off an embarrassing loss ten
days ago they're finally getting a
little bit of rest they're finally gonna
come back also I like betting on Andrew
Luck I hear that especially if Tremayne
Johnson and Buster's screener out and I
got Andrew Luck in a hurry up
all those big guys up front are not
gonna matter
it's Nayeem hines it's Jordan Wilkins
it's all those other receivers with
quick throws right I look at this game
and I think really good teams win
back-to-back games I don't think the
Jets are a really good team I think the
Jets are in you're 6 and 10 maybe 7 and
9 and those are teams that when they win
they lose that's the kind of French
that's where they are right now
in this rebuild right and also I looked
and I said you know what I'm not gonna
fall into this the Jets have found their
running thing this is how the Jets have
done in rushing yards every game this
year starting from week one yeah
tell me if you see a trend this is net
yards rushing 169 42 107 34 323 they're
an up and down team yeah they they're
all over the place I just see the Colts
coming back and and and surprising it I
want to find you know 100 100 I got $100
in the Colts right would you fart
outside what is a Jermaine Johnson what
is it he's questionable practice right
so he's he'll dealing with the
concussion thing right no that was
Buster scream Tremaine has a quad he's a
quad okay yeah you go with that all
right
next game 1 o'clock slate Arizona
Cardinals one in four on the road
visible so the reason I took the Colts
is like everything in my power to polish
[Music]
everything dude when I first looked that
was like Jets definitely and then I went
oh no it's not definitely and then the
Andrew Luck factor almost made me pick
them outright and I don't think they're
the better team so yeah it's it's very
tough that's why I'm betting $50 I just
don't trust it next game here guys
Arizona Cardinals one in four on the
road visiting the two two and one
Minnesota Vikings the Vikings are a ten
and a half point favorite at home left
go we'll start with you all right
Arizona is banged up missing practice
Wednesday and never being healthy Larry
Fitzgerald also tre Boston Robert Kim
dici he knew else missed practice for
the Cardinals three offensive linemen
damn Andre Smith my Caillou potty DJ
Humphries ever we saw I you potty get
take it off right Andre Smith's been
banged up all year or so TJ Humphries
missing practice for Minnesota starting
right tackle Riley Reef and Andrew sand
dae-ho it's a groin injury that scares
me a lot yeah Dalvin cook limited in
practice trae Waynes is officially back
I'll be putting also one more thing let
me see if I can finally it's Garrett
thank you mr. Paul lady no problem
big big help yep big help whatever you
need we're okay here it is
ah all right it's gonna come up in a
different game but oh here it is this is
the eighth game this year where there is
a team in the NFL favored by nine or
more the favorites and those are four
and three straight up two and five
against the spread so all the teams that
have had huge favorites in Minnesota so
those Buffalo have not been great I am
still putting $100 on Minnesota air
Minnesota is seven and three Minnesota
hello Minnesota Vikings fans I know
you're gun-shy but I want you to know
that this week is different
this isn't Buffalo this is an Arizona
since no the Cardinals since moving
Arizona in 1988 have never won in
Minnesota hmm a lot like the Falcons in
Pittsburgh there oh and eight in
Minnesota there too and six against the
spread and in their last 10 home games
Minnesota is seven and three against the
spread eight and two straight up I
thought about this game the one thing
about Josh Rosen the man likes to take
shots I didn't like their offense as a
whole last week and if San Francisco
could not make mistakes and CJ Beathard
wasn't having fumbles and throwing weird
picks San Francisco could have won that
game right and San Francisco has no
right to even be in a game I will give
credit to Arizona they have a good
defense their defense has done pretty
well other than that Rams blowout
they've really kept some teams in front
of them they've had some success but I
think this is a game where a lot like
I'm gonna talk about Buffalo later where
Arizona is coming off a win and they're
going to Minnesota and Minnesota's not
gonna get fooled fool me once shame on
me fool Malloy twice I'm gonna punch so
let me can't fool me again can't fool me
again so I'm going Minnesota even though
it's a really big line I just I think
Minnesota's defense I think rosin throws
a few picks yeah yeah there's there's a
let's see how do I want to start with
this I guess I would start with the
Cardinals offense I'll start there the
Cardinals offense force of Vikings
defense yeah I don't like the matchup
it's it's big trouble
there's no way I just wouldn't be
absolutely shocked if the Cardinals can
move the ball consistently yeah maybe
they do make some big shots something
like that I think it's the only way I
can see that happening okay yeah I'm
gonna a whole rant about how their wide
receivers are slurs not to Richie
exactly I was like then I don't know
what they're gonna run games not good
David Johnson is relying on the one play
and heat up yeah exactly so I have no
faith in Arizona's offense being able to
move the ball unless some floki things
happen I really don't the other side of
the other side of the realm there is you
know the Vikings the Vikings offense
it's not rolling yet it's not perfect I
get that but one thing I do know is Kirk
Cousins is capable of making big throws
in the pass game on a weekly basis
Arizona yes they got Patrick Peter said
but other than Chandler Jones he's
really their biggest difference maker on
the front seven I just have a hard time
looking at Arizona and going they're
going to slow them down enough I don't
think this is gonna be a blowout like a
34:10 type football game but I just
don't know how Arizona can keep pace in
this type of football game I think the
Vikings win a comfortable kind of ugly
dominant football game 24 to 10 I'm
putting $100 on the Viking you're
feeling pretty good about I put about a
hundred dollars on you I see this as a
twenty seven to seven win yeah I can see
that too write that down it's gonna be
right I could see that twenty seven to
ten seven so you're just taking a field
goal
27:10 right I said 27 10 no 27 seven all
right yeah and I said 24 10 scores okay
we're good next game here guys
Pittsburgh at Cincinnati spread in this
game is Cincinnati - two and a half
samms will go to you first okay
Cincinnati Pittsburgh oh man injuries
Morgan Burnett missed practice he's
missed the last three games Vince
Williams is back is that a big deal it
is the Steelers especially for the run
game that's where that's gonna help them
with everything really he's their best
athletic middle linebacker right now
Bengals have been
very banged up and practiced Giovanni
Bernard miss practiced Billy price still
out the starting center that they
drafted Clint bowling is now missing
price to their starting gar with a hip
injury John Ross is back could be for
like two quarters though cuz he'll be
back out right all right go for it yeah
okay so I mean I expect this game to be
extremely close I mean really a one
score tight football game my biggest
thing here I think that both of these
offenses can have their way to a degree
I guess I would look at the Cincinnati
Bengals offense and just go I don't see
how Pittsburgh secondary is going to
slow down their passing attack I really
don't I think that it's a diverse enough
attack Andy Dalton's played well enough
they do enough thing schematically to
where I'm sold now that they're capable
of making plays and on a consistent
basis week to week I guess Pittsburgh
defense the only way I could see them
really ruining this game you know is if
Cameron Hayward and to it they got a
destroy they have to destroy the
interior part of the Bengals offensive
line throughout the game and with those
injuries it's a little scary it really
is that does scare me now I think if I
flip it over to the other side I think
Pittsburgh's able to move the ball and
the Cincinnati Bengals as well I just
think Cincinnati though has more talent
on that side of the ball to maybe make a
stand once or twice during the game and
oh we can play man-to-man and put a
William Jackson on Antonio Brown in a
big situation and maybe double juju
semester in the mr. Smith Shuster in the
middle because of that I think this is a
close football game I'm just going with
the home football team here well I'm
going $50 on the Cincinnati Bengals and
I think they're going to win the game 24
to 21 how do you are to that little bang
go cat don't do that it was great
alright I am going to be putting 145
dollars on the pittsburgh steelers
beautiful that's a random number plus
two and a half I've made a chart
it's a circle it's the circle of life
it's called the circle of the AFC North
teams not including Cleveland Cincinnati
is faster than Baltimore we saw that yes
Baltimore is bigger than Pittsburgh
right I think Pittsburgh is stronger
than Cincinnati bigger stronger faster
here's why I'm wrong Cincinnati this
year is four and one against the spread
tied for second best in the NFL only
behind I believe the Chiefs have the
part of a perfect five I know Cincinnati
has offi also covered five of their last
six games at home right they had no
business covering last week no business
which is part of the reason why I love
Pittsburgh here it's the first time
since 2015 that Cincinnati is favored in
a game over the Steelers why because
since Andy Dalton's rookie year
Cincinnati is 3 and 11 against
Pittsburgh and in the last nine games
Pittsburgh against Cincinnati is eight
and one and seven and two against the
spread Cincinnati
always has Baltimore's number and I
think the Steelers always have
Cincinnati sambar right and when I look
at and I look at Cincinnati and I see
that they're banged up Pittsburgh is
still in we got to keep winning our
lives are on the line yes they are
Cincinnati's for and one their reporters
have been in the locker room what's it
like to be underrated why is everyone
sleeping on you now you're taking on big
brother by the way when reporters tell
players that another franchise is big
brother I don't think it's good for
those players because then they're gonna
be like yeah they are big brother so
that if anything bad happens I'll big
brothers bashing you in the face this
levian stuff I think James Connor is
gonna be running really hard in
Cincinnati you can have some success
against and also look men like they were
down 70 nothing to the dolphins yeah
they let up 36 points to Atlanta and it
took a great drive at the end there to
make it happen they did get beat up
against Carolina you know they haven't
looked that great the last few weeks so
I look at Pittsburgh I just think
they're the better team and I thought
that this was gonna be Pittsburgh - like
I really did like
I thought I thought that they would
think the public was underselling
Cincinnati I think I'm getting the
better football team and I don't like I
think Annie dalton has Baltimore's
number and I think he does not have
Pittsburgh no yeah I mean you can't
argue that he has not had their number I
mean the Bengals have not had the
Steelers number all together I think our
guy juju goes off you think juju goes on
I think it's the underneath slant guy
where I don't I don't see Antonio Brown
going off as much because I think those
corners are the perfect corners to match
out with Antonio Brown right but I think
it's the Juju's and the Vance McDonald's
that go off in this gate and and this
will be this is a toss-up football game
is going I think the Bengals are the
better football team that's the only
reason I wanted their home and I just
think they're slightly better I think
there's too much pressure in my big all
right guys moving on here the LA
Chargers sitting at 3 & 2 all we just
ask you one question I only bet 50 on
that that's that's why your money's on
Cincinnati yeah and you're watching this
game right alright when you're watching
the game do you think you're gonna be
happy your money's on Andy Dalton or do
you you're gonna be like man I kind of
wish my money is on better no I I always
think of things like that
I always that's what I did with the
Colts game I was like I want my money on
Andrew Luck yeah I get that I get that
but I've also had those thoughts some
weeks and it doesn't come out to be for
like you know oh Bayless I wanted Aaron
Rodgers against yeah exactly I was so
circumcised yeah so I just I don't know
I just
the Pittsburgh is a little bit of a
dumpster fire I mean they were
dominating the game last week and had
first and goal in the one at 13 to 10
and big been through a jump ball in the
triple coverage so I just don't trust
them right now the Bengals like I have a
little trust factor for it that's a
crazy scent I know even if they've
showed it to me even then even their one
loss the game was 2421 and they had the
ball late in the game and Dalton threw a
bad throw and that's that is the scary
part
next game here guys three and to LA
Chargers on the road visiting the 2 2 &
1
Cleveland Browns ooh spread in this game
Chargers -1 left go give us the injuries
and then Chris your breakdown first okay
one of my favorite games of the weekend
injuries jeté vez Brown for the Chargers
linebacker missed practice with a groin
and Caleb Sturgis was living
their kicker with a quad and I believe
that they are looking at other kickers
right now which is very interesting in a
place where there's been a lot of
kicking issues Cleveland
Rashard Higgins missed practice for
Cleveland other than that they're pretty
clean
okay all right so let's start there I
mean I guess I would go here the first
thing is the Chargers office the
Chargers offense is special I don't
think there's any way you know around
that it they can do whatever they want
Eldon Gordon's having an amazing an
amazing year and then Phillip Rivers is
also having an amazing year and the
Chargers have two losses I know
against the two best teams in football
the Rams and the Chiefs so I think we
all have to take that way yeah so there
I think the Chargers because they got
off it's it's the old week 1 loss that
it was only the number one game and
Patrick mahomes came out that we've
written them off for the next game and
now I mean let's look at what we've got
here that you also want to say that
they've beaten the bills Niners and
Raiders yeah so they haven't beaten
anyone to give you confidence and the
two losses no confidence I get you and I
thought he did lose those two games
though by a combined 22 points right
right and I mean I look at the the game
like the Buffalo Bills it was
underwhelming and underwhelming in
Buffalo but they won the 49ers game I
don't think they played their best game
there but they found a way to won the
Raiders game last week yeah they won
twenty six to ten but that game was
closer than that - it was I expect this
game to be close I have no faith in the
Chargers defense at this point I do
think the Browns are becoming a
well-rounded offensive football team you
know Baker can throw the football we
know that I don't know if they can make
huge plays in the pass game because I
don't know if they have that speed type
guy Jarvis Landry is here to catch a lot
of ten and eight yard balls and Joe ku
will catch balls down the middle and all
of that but I think really at the end of
the day I have to go with the Chargers
in this matchup because I just don't
trust Cleveland's defense yet
Cleveland's defense lets up too many big
plays and I think when I just look at
them as a whole and go man Cleveland's
defense is 27th and football its 281
yards a game and the pass get in the
past game that's ridiculous
let alone in the in the run game it's a
hundred and sixteen I mean so I didn't
the Chargers are just gonna have a
little too much offense for Cleveland to
keep pace in the football game
because that I'm going a hundred dollars
on the Chargers I expect them to win
2721 on the road mm-hmm I know it's
tough one fan trick oh he's going Browns
here all the way Chargers charge they're
not gonna forget that they lost that
game there two years ago 200 will they
not guys I'm so confident in the Browns
this weekend that I'm feeling a little
too excited in fact I don't got a reason
why I'm wrong let me tell you something
Browns are four and one against the
spread this year tied for again the
second-best line in the NFL it's pretty
damn impressive if you might say in the
last four games the Chargers have played
the Browns there two and two this is not
just a short-term thing this is a
long-term thing
by the way this is just the eighth time
in the last ten years that the Chargers
are a favorite in the Eastern time zone
Sims you know how they did in those
games
not as a favorite three and five to win
six against the spread actually worse
against the Sprint they just out they
lost more than they've won as a favorite
yeah one of those losses 2016 in
Cleveland right
Cleveland's only win of the season it
was their only win for a two-year span
the Chargers are good and then they're
bad they're great on one drive and then
they can't figure it out they go down
the field with Melvin Gordon and they
can't be stopped and they get to the red
zone and nothing makes sense that's who
they are the Browns have an identity and
you know what that identity is what is
it it's a bum fight it's two rats in a
dumpster when you play in Cleveland your
knuckles are gonna be bloodied your
jerseys gonna be
ripped and your kneepads won't exist
when you play against the Browns it is
punching in the face this is a game
where Phillip Rivers will make mistakes
it's early in the morning he doesn't
really know what's going on Myles
Garrett's gonna be in his lap Denzel
Ward's gonna be jumping routes receivers
will be dropping passes Melvin Gordon
will fumble a ball I just see it being
super sloppy and that's the way the
Browns what's the weather are there yeah
what is the weather is the weather most
importantly before he gives the weather
yeah I'm getting the Browns plus one at
home right I love home dogs I love home
dogs dogs II dogs you don't yes what's
the weather Oh guys all right so the
weather for this game high of 60 low of
48 mostly cloudy so it's gonna be a cool
fall day in Cleveland with a Chance of
turnovers for the Chargers look look
think about the Chargers yeah East Coast
1 o'clock game taking on the Patriots
pretty much had the whole game punt
returner runs into the end zone crazy
fumble I just can't pick on that stuff
I'm just telling you I am done you got a
good gut and I love the Browns here
right the Browns know who they are
they're gonna run it with Carlos Hyde
they're gonna find places for Nick Chubb
Baker's gonna throw those passes I trust
the Browns defense I really do and I
know that you say they'll allow some big
place did they allow big place to
Baltimore last week no okay yeah I don't
trust the Chargers defense a lot of big
plays up to the Raiders they did they
did they did they did but I don't know
yeah I like the Browns here I really
envisioned I picked the Chargers to win
this game 27 21 I really put on the
Chargers I put a hundred ok and this
could have easily been another $50 game
for me I really think the Chargers will
be losing late like 2120 and he's just
gonna Cleveland I think Myles Garrett
being the only good pass rusher and then
they just lack one more really good
secondary with all that's that's really
what I just went through it at the end
of the day I just said they lack that
guy other than Denzel I don't know if
they can match up across the board that
was the only reason I did it I almost
made this a lock I'm thinking about
making some questionable games left ko
locks this week below average humidity
in Cleveland on Sunday by the way
Antonio Gates is joints next game here
on the one o'clock slate the Buffalo
Bills visiting the Houston Texans spread
in this game Houston minus nine and a
half left go give us the injuries in
your breakdown injuries Trey Davis white
Micah Hyde for Buffalo and Rafael Bush
are all limited Trey Davis white is an
ankle Micah Hyde groin Rafael Bush
shoulder limited in practice it probably
expected to play yes miss practice for
the Houston Texans to Davian clowny
shocker had an illness okay so it
actually makes me feel better does also
their top three wide receivers DeAndre
Hopkins Kiki Cote and will fuller their
number one running back Lamar Miller and
their quarterback deshaun Watson were
all limited in practice yes they're all
banged up after Dallas right to show him
Watson I imagine spanked he already said
he's playing he got destroyed against it
yes everything in my body wanted me to
take the Buffalo Bills plus nine and a
half yeah everything we've talked about
it Doug McDermott keeps it close yeah
very disciplined all that stuff I'm
going a hundred dollars on the Texans
Texans the Texans here's why I'm wrong
since last year when Houston's been
favored there to enforce straight up one
for and one against the spread also when
Houston has been a favorite of eight or
more points since 2013 there oh and
three against the Sprint right there not
great with pressure since 2017 when
buffalo has been an underdog of eight or
more points it's happened five times in
the last year it's happened five times
they've been underdog eight or more
points they're three and two everything
makes me go ooh
but I'll say this what is Houston
strength Chris Simms I'm gonna I'm gonna
Phil Simms you what is Houston strength
their D line their run D fares right
they're gonna pack it in there we just
saw Zeke have no no structure the last
time Buffalo played a really good run
defense this year it was
one and they got destroyed 47 to 3 by
Baltimore yeah Chargers run defense
isn't that great
Vikings run defense hasn't been that
great Packers run defense isn't that
great and the Titans run defense was
kind of all over the place
also Titans were at home as I've always
said Buffalo to me is a different team
at home yeah I see this as the Houston
puts two wins together game and they
stretch it out and Josh Allen tries to
force some things kind of like he did
last week and Houston's defense without
having a face you know a quarterback
that can dak minimize his issues Josh
Allen hasn't learned that yet yeah and I
look at Houston and I think this is they
get a big DeAndre Hopkins play they have
wide receivers that can man up on some
of these Buffalo quarterbacks after that
can make up for it and I also think I
like that Watson was willing to run last
week he looked like Watson I think that
builds on itself and I think Houston
builds a leak so unfortunately I'm
taking both big favorites to cover but I
it's just because it's a rookie
quarterback in both situation against a
good defense
so I'm taking Houston here to cover yeah
I get you it's gone big on Buffalo no no
it's a close one here it really is I
think this is the way I look at it like
I think you're both bad liars
I'm bad liars Houston's offense is
perfect for Shaun McDermott I'll just
say that interesting just just because
it's again not overly complicated so
he'll be able to do what he normally
does and get a beat on things is that
why the Saints beat the crap out of the
Bills last year well never the Saints
last year just beat beat them to death
and they're running around like it was
like 350 yards I think someone like that
I just wasn't sure if the complex
offenses completely negate his coaching
and then it goes no you're the bills
you're just not that Talent yeah well so
yeah I mean there's a little bit of both
there okay but it's okay you don't have
to shut up I think that the big thing is
so I do look at that and go okay
McDermott I think is gonna have some
moments of going up we've slowed down
Houston and we're doing a pretty good
job here of you know managing this game
I also worry about you know deshaun
Watson that's not a great offensive line
it's not
great run game and McDermott could put
more have his eggs into the let's stop
the pass game basket okay
on the flipside I mean your points what
you said
I mean bubbles often sucks it sucks I
mean it's it's the worst in football
everybody and it's it's because there's
no talent and there's no D offensive
line and it gets this group who's like
starting to come alive on the defensive
line and then okay there's no receivers
in the backend for Houston Texans to be
really scared of you know I just don't
see how they can have sustained success
except for maybe an amazing play here or
there the game played out perfectly for
them last week in the win and then their
other win against the Minnesota Vikings
Kirk Cousins fumbled the ball twice
inside of his own 20-yard line to start
the football game
so that gave him a tremendous jump
barring anything like that I don't see
how Buffalo can win this football game
there's no freaking way and you can't
pull off two miracles in one sense would
they be shocked to miracles in four
weeks like I just would be shocked it's
like lightning striking but I'm jetting
$100 on Buffalo I knew it I'm picking
the Houston Texans to win this game Tom
cotton Tonka I
but 2113 hey you could be right here
this is another game but I was very
tempted to play 2013 21 to 30 so I
stayed true with it got the Buffalo
cover right there this is I think there
are a few plays that Buffalo isn't able
to protect and Houston squeeks out like
a few big like a will fuller play
now obviously I'm worried about everyone
being banged up but Houston just has one
of those teams where everyone's on the
injury report every week it's not as
frustrating as the Patriots who God
bless Bill Belichick makes like 12 guys
limited every week but do you guys like
the Penn system where I guide the picks
and do you really know my truth you
don't like the Penn system I find it
very degrading yeah that's just a
personal thing I kind of feel like a
maestro I like it nearly as degrading as
him looking through his phone when I
talk so don't worry okay I'm looking up
stuff okay last game of the one o'clock
slate here guys the Chicago Bears on the
road visiting to Miami
a hundred dollars in the last game yeah
okay Chicago is three and one that's one
I should've got fifty dollars on that
these are three and two I don't know
anything no I don't either
in this game is bears - three left go
injury Sims we'll go to you I mean I
have been using divergent thinking
Chicago coming off of a bye and they are
feeling healthy Prince Amukamara 's
hamstrings feeling better he's been
limited in practice though still not
full go defensive back Marcus Cooper is
the only guy that missed practice on
Wednesday with a hamstring himself Miami
a little bit more banged up the guys
that missed practice this week cam wake
Bobby McCain and TJ McDonald McDonald's
a foot McCain it's Annie cam wake it's
that ankle limited practice
chicken grant his shoulders a little
banged up and Laremy Tunsil has eight or
had a concussion
one other storyline before we get in
here this is Adam GaSe facing his old
team that's right what do you think
here's him all right well III think the
first thing I would look at is the Miami
offense it's been underwhelming as a
late been disappointed in the overall
schematics if you've listened to
anything we've said on the podcast the
last two weeks have been very simple on
the side of the ball not a good team to
be simple with with the Chicago Bears
other thing that really scares me is
holy crap did the Miami Dolphins
offensive line get their ass whooped
last week against the Cincinnati Bengals
nothing like a cure to your diseases
like the Bears coming to town in that D
line then there's they don't have any
freak son over there
I just think with the scheme being
limited offensive line issues it's gonna
be hard for the Dolphins to move the
football I look at the other side and I
think the Bears are gonna have a hard
time moving the football on the dog
there I do
I mean hey the Miami Dolphins they play
D and let's not forget that yeah the
Bengals scored 27 points last week
before team were because of the Bengals
defense other than the Patriots game
which I would still argue that they
played good football
they just got worn out and had to be on
the field for the first quarter and a
half of the game and if finally that the
dam broke but I think they're gonna give
the Bears all they can handle on that
side of the football - I think what
scares me is the Bears coming off a bye
going down to Miami is always a little
bit of a
rap okay but at the end of the day I am
betting $50 on the better football team
and I'm going with the Chicago Bears and
I think they're gonna win
what's that little dolphin
oh I eat things in the water too 20 to
17 pairs left Oh your breakdown you're
about to put 500 on the Patriots aren't
you Tom is the greatest I have nice food
I have some statistics ooh I have he's
coming hard right here also in trends
and I have a nugget - I'm gonna let go
sprinkle if you wish is it a McDonald's
nugget or you know Shake Shack has
nuggets now do that yeah just add it to
the menu big deal here in New York oh
yeah way to talk over my sprinkle sound
effect wait ready for Nick and now it's
time for my pick of Chicago Miami hi
welcome to the show I'm your host Adam
Lefko and this is possibly a lock it's a
sicko lock but it's because I am a sicko
I am betting $100 on Miami plus three
here is the reason I am wrong I am wrong
because the Bears are for no against the
AFC with true Biscay straight up and
against the spread now the Bears as road
favorites since 2014
oh and two against the spread we already
saw how they played on the road as a
favorite against Arizona this year like
a dead dog that I made a left go luck
and I went good your phone is a big drop
Oh God wipe that thanks for that
sprinkle do the sprinkle effects there
Nick holy [ __ ] your shirt back it's on
my wrist
damn I mean that was an all time for
that no it didn't even
Bart flew it was huge nuggets of saliva
I promised nuggets he's got slobber all
over the death gum on it you ain't over
to wipe this down I'm not even kidding
it's all over it that's all right
my cousin good he doesn't wipe it on the
paper - it's been there the whole time
what is happening all right we good
crying seriously the Dolphins
under gase as a home underdog seven and
five seven four and one against the
spread and now for my cone nugget
Oh mark calm the legend of Mark cone I
was texting with cone earlier and I said
I think I'm taking Miami as I like it he
goes Miami is averaging 28 points per
game at home and only 15 on the road
they're a different team at home they
got Albert Wilson going deep at home
they got chicken Grande they got the
Raiders they're doing a little creative
stuff against the Titans all that stuff
twenty-eight points at home get them
hell out here he played the Raiders they
suck unti hey it was funny they're not
the best they're just cone nuggets the
reason I look at it is this is I know
the one thing that gave me pause is I
went okay I obviously don't know how
Negi is after a bye but I do know how we
did to start the season
yeah and they started off like
firecrackers so when they had a long
time to prepare for somebody that you
went up 21 nothing on the Packers Nagy's
offense has a problem and the problem is
is once he gets past scripted plays it's
kaput yeah area the Bears
spent two weeks here and about how back
they are how great they are
try Biscay goes out there throws six
touchdowns against the Tampa Bay Bucs
and their world beaters they've watched
Aaron Rodgers lose they've like mate
they've watched Minnesota be super
averaged Detroit's been up and down
where all along their B ACK back the
Dolphins have been told for two weeks
how much of a fraud they were
you were frauds you were three you know
when it was a mistake yeah 17 nothing
against Cincinnati blow it all away I
think that the Bears come out a little
flat Josh what is the weather gonna be
down there Oh what is the weather gonna
be in Miami let me get it for you guys
it is gonna be 90 degrees and partly
cloudy I'll get you the humidity in one
second now keep talking I'm gonna pull
it out okay
it's gonna be hot it's a beautiful Miami
October sauna Chicago's gonna come in
they're feeling themselves they're gonna
watch the game film and they're gonna be
like Khalil max ability
I mean Tanner hills thrown it to the
defensive lineman
I can't wait to run for my touch down
80% humidity 80% humidity I mean I can't
think of a giant of a bear that wears us
use the matter but global warming it's
80 in Chicago all week - sorry buddy I
just think that this is a team that's
really feeling themselves and if Adam
what do you want to say 45-minute
dolphins breakdown love it if the
Dolphins lose this game Adam GaSe his
job is on the line it really is like if
you think about it all the changes
they've made and if you lose three in a
row after winning three you know now I
go where's the stability where's the
culture I think this is a team that is
fighting for their lives in a sauna yeah
against a team that's been feeling
themselves Chicago four o'clock watts on
this one call you watch all the cramps
early on for Chicago you're well-rested
and you're playing in a sauna - and you
know what I mean the Bears players have
been focused I saw something
where one of their running backs get a
Bar Mitzvah in New York that's that
doesn't sound focused to me no all right
guys sounds like he said his ass up I I
went through and looked yeah I picked 11
underdogs this week and four favorites I
think this is gonna be a crazy week all
right guys so we're moving adamah games
here it's like two seconds I can't do it
right now I got other thing for ya I've
got a legitimate your bets I've got a
legitimately scary weather report to go
along with this game so we're starting
off with four o'clock games on the
random computer Rams visiting the Denver
Broncos the weather
forecast for Denver on Sunday is snow
right now but right now the forecast in
Denver according to weather calm high of
28 low of 15 snow in the forecast now
let me just read the temperatures before
the game and after the game today in
Denver 48 tomorrow 63 Saturday 58 it's
gonna drop to 28 on Sunday but then it's
gonna go back up to 41 on Monday 53 on
Tuesday 56 on Wednesday god it was a
Bronco the 60s later next week snow in
Denver on Sunday that's correct it's
crazy same with you it makes me want to
change my bet let me just give the
injury concussions right now
Brandon cook I'm scared I'm freaking out
Brandon cooks and Cooper Cup Sean
McVeigh is hopeful they both play
Zuerlein groin injury right now missed
practice and they got another kicker
though he's been there for a while by
the way the Chargers signed another
kicker whose last name is bagged badly
for that game
they're very unsure of who they be
playing just for that game Denver Jared
Ville dears expected to miss another
game at right tackle Sims you went into
detail yesterday about how the other
guys that have played there Billy Turner
especially not fared well right Adam
Jones and Darian Stewart two guys in the
secondary missed practice on Wednesday
and Garrett bulls is limited with an
ankle he has five holding penalties
already this season so both starting
tackles could be in trouble for Denver
Sims your pick that's a that's a little
bit of an issue for sure okay it's the
team with that D line that D line scary
I mean this defense is still good don't
be fooled by you know some big plays
some mental mishaps on the back end that
I don't think we're gonna continue to be
part of the structure of the overall
defense of the Los Angeles Rams who
still have the ninth best defense in
football and are only letting up
nineteen point six points per game I
think the big thing is this really
Denver is a very tough place to play I
know that the Broncos are going to give
an all-world
effort this week they lost a
heartbreaker to Kansas City and we're
absolutely embarrassed last week in the
New York Jets you talk about a guy you
talk about gates and being on the hot
seat Vance Joseph seats already hot he
might
lost one ass-cheek already just in the
last five days because it got that hot
so I'll tell you what it's gonna be cold
on Sunday cuz I'd be snow it things off
certainly and if I wish I would have
known that maybe I wouldn't have picked
such a high score I don't think there's
any as much as I like some of the things
this Broncos defense does everybody's
been able to move the ball to it agree
when they need to when they need to
exactly at all right Oakland Oakland
Kansas City right Baltimore did I mean
we hired last week cuz they're small
they are a little small
certainly there are little unsound
certain things they do and you're
playing the most well-rounded offense in
football and I just look on the other
side and hey I think Case Keenum will be
aggressive and take some shots and makes
a few plays against this Rams defense
and this game stays closed I'm putting
$50 on the Broncos because of their
desperation just absolute desperation
that's why but I think the Rams are
gonna win this football game 31 to 28
it's a tough place to play in Denver I
could certainly attest to that
so you said that GaSe is on the hot seat
and I said he's gonna show up and you
said well if that's the case Vance is on
the hot seat the difference is it
doesn't matter if you're on the hot seat
if you're not a good coach I'm willing
to say that sure okay I think Vance
Joseph is one of the most honorable
overmatch coaches in the NFL
however matched you know what he is
under as a coach in the last 17 games
against the spread Vance Joseph Wright
what to 14 and 1 Wow okay
Denver's not a tough place to play in
fact Denver is one in seven against the
spread in their last eight at home only
covering that Seattle game earlier this
year when it you know it could have
really gone either way
yeah I am putting $100 on the Rams this
is this is the sixth time in the last
ten years that Denver is an underdog of
six or more points at home Vegas agrees
with you
Vegas rarely makes that vert underdog
like this in those five games before
this one in four straight up one in four
against the spread yeah under McVeigh
the Rams are six no against the AFC in
his career
and one against the spread when the Rams
are favored by six or more he's six and
oh five and one against the spread the
only one didn't happen would be the
Seahawks game last week I the snow is
interesting it is but I am NOT betting
on weather anymore that snow could come
Saturday night I don't know
got burned by the Hurricanes week one
that's right I am going with the Rams
because I'm going with the better team
because I think Case Keenum is
unreliable and he's turned into the Case
Keenum from two years ago and I think
we're realizing that man Thielen and
Diggs were really really freaking good I
also look at Denver and I see their to
tackle injuries and I think about the
Rams d-line I also think about the Rams
and Marcus Peters getting beat and I
don't think that's gonna continue again
I think if there's the best player on
the field
it's Todd Gurley and then I think if you
really say who's the best player on the
field I don't even know if von Miller's
in the top two or three which is a wild
thing to say for Von Miller there's that
many he's probably three I'm gonna put
him after Todd Gurley and I'm gonna put
him after Aaron Donald I agree and so I
look at Denver I think they're super
unreliable I haven't liked the way
they've looked I don't think that they
have anything to stand their hat on I
think that they gave everything in their
heart in that Chiefs game and I think
that hangover is gonna last for a little
bit longer and I want to get my money in
on the Rams okay seven is definitely
scary yeah I couldn't do that
this is too much rain that's a tough
place they'll do it it's look I know
against the spread they're not good or
whatever me I'm getting one of the least
qualified coaches in the NFL against the
best coach in the NFL and even though
the Rams sometimes it stalls out I'm a
little bit worried about the health of
these receivers that machine was still
running with those two guys off Robert
woods look like a number one receiver
all their tight ends what Gurley can do
Denver scares me I look Mattia Denver
had the fifth pick of the draft last
year and because they started off the
games the year strong we're like it's
Denver Denver and my mind is small Petco
is not a guy that's gonna be out there
for 6070 snaps he's just not yeah and I
look at their linebackers I think
they're all undersized yeah I look at
their secondary it's not what it's
in the last few years oh they're coming
off an East Coast trip and the Rams just
got a scare and they just went for it on
fourth down and said let's be the
[ __ ] man I hear you I know hey listen
the the the the Broncos can't score
points I mean that's been one of the
things it's a lot of settling for field
goals or moving the ball between the 30s
and that's where it's scary against a
team like this another thing I'll just
say take into account is just the
Broncos can run the ball they've had
moments of being successful if there's
one weakling we've seen with the Rams
defense like we saw last week you can do
it just food for thought also gonna add
this thus far Sims and I have agreed on
eight excuse me we've agreed on three
and we've disagreed on eight it's a
moving week all right guys moving on to
the 425 slot here Steve mica mica on the
call for this one it is the Baltimore
Ravens at three and two the Tennessee
Titans at three and two game is in
Nashville spread in this one Baltimore -
three left go I know you are excited to
hear Steve on the broadcast steel mica
make Baltimore Tennessee this is the
game that I circled two games that I
really don't know what's gonna happen
yes this game and the next game injuries
Michael Pierce Baltimore and Brandon
Carr so the defensive tackle and corner
missed practice on Wednesday pair Lee
Taylor lawanna is a very serious foot
injury miss practice on Wednesday and
they're not sure if he's gonna play
probably why he looked so poor against
the Buffalo Bills like so on a sense
Wesley Woodyard limited after missing
the game against Buffalo he didn't play
they're not sure if he's gonna play I'm
gonna be putting $100 on Tennessee plus
three Baltimore is coming off of an
yes after losing at Buffalo I have
self-corrected I have talked to Queens
verses I have spoke to my daughter her
meticulous and I am ready I've spoken to
my cousin Hawaii that looks over my
little nephew Mariota huh and I told him
one thing in your eyes the Lightning
port will sign clear so who'd you pick
there I may just hear that again
Tennessee you pick Tennessee Tennessee
+3 100 Baltimore's coming off an
overtime loss so again remember I do the
whole overtime it's a real thing teams
that have played in overtime teams that
have played in overtime the next week
I'm just adding about myself there now 3
and 9
ok ok 2 teams won last week right two
teams with young athletic quarterbacks
Baker Mayfield - Sean Watson right they
got it done but teams coming off of an
overtime loss are one in three damn you
know just made me think houston that's
two weeks in a row they've played it
into overtime they have and not if that
hurts them and not great against Buffalo
yeah if you want the full breakdown if
you tied your Owen for the next game if
you're coming off an overtime loss
they've been one in three if you're
coming off an overtime win there are two
and two right still feeling pretty good
yeah last four times that Tennessee has
been a home underdog three and one
straight up for now against the spread
in their last 10 home games
Tennessee has covered eight of their
last 10 and since 2016 after a loss
Tennessee their next game against the
spread 12 and 3 the reason I went here
with Tennessee because I thought about
it Sims I said Tennessee's offense we
don't know what it is it sure is a lot
of stuff in the middle of field and
Baltimore loves to beat you in a box and
Joe Flacco man his wide receivers are
gonna open but maybe they can find a way
with Alex Collins and Jeff aureus
Allen's and all those tight ends but
then I thought left ko you're not
betting on Baltimore on the road not
again ok there are 77 and 13 straight up
in their last 20 road games there
ten nine and one against the spread
they're an average team I think they're
losing this one I think Tennessee is a
home dog i tennessee has shown to be a
very good home team yeah and so if I get
three points I'm taking it at home in
what I think is a coin flip game yeah
let's not forget that you know there's
the Dean P's factor bang that was my
other thing too in Baltimore right and
he's he's Baltimore it came from you
know now he's on Tennessee practices
against Marty morningway no morning wag
to a degree certainly and yes that would
go well morning leghul no Dean peas as
well but I just think the guy that has
the edge in that matchup is Dean P and
it doesn't matter cuz Barney morning
Wake is stubborn and he's gonna throw at
sixty times he certainly he certainly
could and I don't have like this
tremendous faith in their run game
anyways I mean it's solid i again i
don't think they're running backs are
that special i think they have a big
offensive line but they haven't shown me
the ability to be consistently good at
that yet i think they have a lot of
potential to be good there and that is a
little bit of a weakness to the
Tennessee Titans defense because they do
so much stuff up front slanting blitzing
twisting they get caught off guard
sometimes with with defending the run
but I do think that Baltimore on their
offensive side of the ball it's just not
overly complex enough to fool a Dean
Pease I think he'll be all over some
concepts and when there's moments when
he's worried about stopping the run I
think their corners can match up against
that that group their Baltimore wants to
overpower you yes and then catch on a
play-action but if you're prepared for
it I and I have a hard time thinking
that happens where is the pass rusher to
take advantage of Taylor LaJuan not
being there yeah agreed right I hear you
so in Tennessee so I looking at that
that's out of the ball and then yeah I
think if I look at Tennessee with their
offense it's not gonna be pretty
either I mean it's not but I think I'm
just going with them at home and I don't
trust Baltimore I don't think it really
came down to anything more than that
Hine Road man screw I'm putting a
hundred dollars oh you're really feeling
it on the Titans
and I expect them to win the game 17 to
16 but I think this is the purpose Sims
have joined me am I
fight against Baltimore on the road
goodbye ladies when the Raven fries from
his nest I shall clip its wing eat its
beak and take its feet were super oh
that is soft of you I will take my sword
and snap this raven as he flies by me I
will keep Edgar Allan Poe in the couch
oh my gosh I forgot who Edgar Allan Poe
is hawk the Raven never I knew he's a
poet it's good thus far I want to give
an update
let's see Sims his reaction I bet you he
gets upset Sims you've bet on thus far
yeah eight favorites and for underdogs
okay that's good you like that yeah I'm
okay with that
all right guys three games to go here
last game of the afternoon slate the
three and two Jacksonville Jaguars on
the road visiting the 2 & 3 Dallas
Cowboys this game is gonna be great
by the way David Irving is actually
playing in this game this game
Jacksonville - 3 a la I've forgot a
point I wanted to say in Alaska say it
say it say it say it say it say it so I
say it's very similar teams big physical
as the mantra Titans have a few more
skill guys that was more than my last
thing to go they I just think they have
one or two guys that I think can make
more plays in the Ravens sorry spread in
this game Jacksonville - three left go
give us the injuries and then Chris
you'll break it down okay here are the
injuries as you know that Leonard
fournette is gonna miss this one Leonard
for a Nets been battling a hamstring
injury people are saying they're gonna
wait until after the bye
get that man arrested don't look now
though his backup grant also out they
went and signed Jamaal Charles knew else
missed practice on Wednesday Sims Yeldon
- big old players coleus Campbell and
Malik Jackson Malik Jackson it's a back
coleus Campbell it's an ankle Josh wells
the starting left tackle after they lost
Ken Robinson not practicing either groin
injury if he doesn't play you know who
starts of course you don't Josh Walker
who's never started a game in the NFL or
guess who they could bring in yes he
visited this week Eric [ __ ] flowers
buckle up here we go because the Cowboys
know all about him when I look at Alice
I do not like
I honestly thought that made sense
they'll turn him around you watch he's
gonna go down it's like one of the
they're gonna be like I'm working back
whoa this guy missing practice for
Dallas Shawn Lee right and DeMarcus
Lauren sat out with a shoulder but
they're expecting him to play got you
this is gonna be a brutal unplug fob sum
for this game I mean this is this is
football okay I'm I'm kind of I don't
like 45:41 that's not fun to me okay I
want this game to be said that one to be
blood pain and I think that's what it'll
be I think it's gonna be I will be along
those I'm picking the game to be 22 13
and I'm not gonna tell you who yet
business call it Jacksonville's defense
has one issue it's stopping the run but
okay that's stopping the run it's an
issue maybe when they have to worry
about a pass game like Jacksonville has
got nothing to worry about in this game
they have no threat whatsoever so
they're gonna be able to focus on
stopping the run on some of these power
sets that the Dallas Cowboys do have a
hard Tim to thinking the Cowboys can
move the ball much also the other side I
have a hard time thinking Jacksonville
can move the ball much on the Dallas
Cowboys either but I do think that
Jacksonville's o-line is still a force
to be reckoned with and Nate Hackett I
have more trust and his ability to
devise a game plan to take advantage of
Dallas in the past game a little bit
more than I do
Linehan versus my man Todd wash with the
Jacksonville Jaguars ha ha Todd I think
this game is really close really
physical I'm putting $100 on the Jaguars
to win this game 20 to 13 let's go this
is interesting like T to cowboy I've
seen the Cowboys turn their ranch
and I would like to ingest their insides
it's like scary gay it actually kind of
sounds like who is the cowboy in The Big
Lebowski oh it does a little bit it's
like you sound more like Penelope Cruz
husband when he's the crazy murderer guy
I almost said nacho libre no but it was
your breakdown on this game wow there's
no reason for me to rush um what's his
name in that movie I don't know he's
like out in the wild well I'll look
what's his name javi are Bart go ahead
just okay talk about your game okay so
I'm just gonna give my trip for Country
for Old Men oh that's how he talks
yes yeah I don't know any lines and
they're not a quotable movie last ten
times as a home underdog
Dallas is three and seven three six and
one against the spread jacksonville
against the NFC since 2013 4 and 16
straight up and it gives the sprint but
left go they were really bad before that
well if you include last year two
against the NFC the Jaguars are two and
three straight up and against the spread
and that includes barely beating the
Giants earlier this year in what was a
very ugly game now the Cowboys are
coming off an overtime loss and again
teams are one in three after overtime
losses and again I went back and forth
this was a very hard game but damn it
yeah I'm diggin the Dallas Cowboys plus
three home give all giddy up give me
that horsing keep it out myself that's
right Todd I'm on the back we're gonna
finish Oh Blake bortles guess what's
coming at your face pal David Irving
coming around the edge - Marcus Lawrence
hi throw it off that random offensive
lineman's face mask that you've never
seen before just kidding it's Eric
flowers we gonna be digging them flowers
gonna put that on my wife's souffle I
feel like I got to pick up my game with
that stuff you're blowing me away with
your stuff this year blowing right I
started the animal noises and you've
just you take it to another look at what
I do here but I look at Dallas and I go
there I think that
do you think this were like yeah square
prediction I honestly think that I for
some reason earlier today I was like I
could see this being surprisingly
high-scoring but then I was like you're
being an idiot don't say that I think
this is gonna be a 24:14 Cowboys win and
I think it's gonna be a game where I
really think that Zeke and them are
gonna want to pound early and I think
that the Jaguars are gonna be a little
shell-shocked after what just happened
right look I didn't have the Jaguars
making the playoffs this year because I
saw a lot of those close games bouncing
the other way yeah and so I wanted to
remember you know I have the Cowboys
making the playoffs and I have the
Jaguars not and I think these are the
games that define those seasons I think
that bortles is gonna face arguably the
best pass rush that he's faced all year
I mean yes that's a hundred percent 100
percent and what the Cowboys defense did
to a Houston Texans team he's played all
year the Dallas Cowboys defenses for
real yes it is and I think they match up
really well with the Jaguars I do and so
when that happens then I start looking
at special teams and the real thing is
is will the Cowboys protect the ball
against the Jaguars
I think the Cowboys are going all-in on
the run this week
I think it's screen city I think it's
draw City
I think it's pounding it with Zeke city
yeah the Cowboys overcorrect because
their owner over speaks so what happens
is when the head of the company goes we
need to run the ball more we need to hit
the ball to Zeke Moore they're going to
frickin do it and I think that's what's
gonna happen I think that Jaguars are I
think this is the first week not the
first week but the first week this year
where the defense is sitting there
watching film and they're going you know
man our quarterback sucks like we spent
all summer talking about how this guy's
not that bad but like look at this and
what's gonna happen is they're gonna
over commit they're gonna over pursue
because they're gonna have to
overcorrect for a quarterback that's
making mistakes I think we're gonna see
a Tavon Austin deep ball I think that
our guy I'm even going as far to say
what's that tight end oh I've been
thinking about our old
Darwyn Blake Jah ruins gonna catch a
touchdown what's this catch output right
now
this dude's coming on our pot it's not
it's not on pace for what did he say mid
35 it's not on pace for that no he's not
coming on our podcast if he doesn't get
he hasn't shaves eyebrow and it's got
one catch yes for 11 yards yeah I was
just writing cashes your eyebrow can't
cash visioning how left go would fit in
in the Jaguars defensive film room we
have to make sure we look up our buddy I
can't remember his name off the tough
item so we can you know I think Dallas
wins this game and I think it's a little
bit comfortable and I think it's the
first time that Jacksonville is feeling
like a two-game losing streak pressure
in a while because biggest weapon I
think that Jacksonville's disappointed
after the Chiefs I think Dallas is going
holy [ __ ] right this is the first time
that Jason Garrett I don't think has had
the support of Jerry Jones yeah and when
that happens desperation Dallas time
yeah I'm loving my picks right now good
alright guys moving by the way has now
picked nine favorites Sunday Night
Football the five and OH Kansas City
Chiefs on the road to Foxborough
visiting the save Sims because this is a
hundred percent where he's putting all
this money three and two New England
Patriots a reminder for everyone tune in
to football night in America our very
own Chris Sims is going to be on the
pregame show we're gonna be doing Sims
memes you know what kind I actually have
someone texted me about when you're
going on it'll probably be I know I have
two segments one on my home's one on
Brady start it starts at 7:00 yes I
think the first one I'm on is like NBC
NBC right the first one of mine is gonna
be in one of those first three or four
segments then my homes breakdown will be
later on I'm just not sure exactly one
yet but closer to kick-off I believe so
when Sims goes on TV vendrick will take
some pictures put it on social we're
gonna put the picture you put the words
on it what the mean is but then also you
guys grab random pictures because josh
isn't gonna get all the weirdness right
so catch a try-catch Sims with his mouth
open catch when he's listening and he's
like making a smirk god forbid he rubs
his mouth or his nose get that I won't
have spread in this game New England -
three and a half left go you're gonna go
first here are the injuries
first of all Sims your fears have been
answered Sammy Watkins and Dee Ford are
good to go they will be playing now
Justin Houston with this ham straight my
$500 bet here thank god they're playing
Eric Murray you're definitely on
Patriot's it's okay
Eric Morean is ankle and Eric Berry are
all missing practices so Justin Houston
will be interesting to watch the
starting safeties right now for Kansas
City our rut we're gonna hurry up we're
gonna hurry up you [ __ ] god damn it the
starting safeties right now for the
Chiefs are Ron Parker and Jordan Lucas
and the third safety is Josh Shaw who
was signed last week New England list
everybody is limited but Malcolm Browns
the one that liked my crease the
reporter up there is like it'll be
interesting to watch I am putting $100
on the Chiefs plus three and a half
another underdog and I'm obsessed here's
the reason every freaking trend is in
their favor as an undefeated underdog in
the last 15 years teams that are
undefeated
but our underdogs are four and one
straight up and against the spread at
this point of the year Andy Reid since
he started it at Kansas City is
two-and-oh against Bill Belichick in
those two games he's outscored them 83
to 41 Kansas City is the only team that
is five and OH against the spread this
season since 2016 Kansas City is seven
and two straight up and against the
spread as an underdog in their last ten
primetime gains Kansas City is 9 and 1
in their last 10 home prime time games
the Patriots are eight and two one of
those two losses is Kansas City I am
taking Kansas City I think it's gonna be
a shootout I also could see the Patriots
just working that defense and winning by
a lot I'm gonna turn it over to you but
before you go can you tell me who is the
better tight end right now Gronk or
Kelsey and who's a better tight end all
time I think well Gronkowski's the
better Ted into all time Gronkowski is
the best tight end ever
and for me um I think Kelsey has
surpassed him in the pass game I do
he's still not the blocker Gronkowski's
Gronkowski can block defense ends and
they can go okay
need to run the ball here we need you to
block him man-to-man he could do that
Kelsey Kelsey is not quite up to that
level but as a receiving threat you take
college yeah Kelsey's passed him up I
think just Kelty Kelsey moves better
he's better in and out of cuts now
Gronkowski like a horse right he can do
more after the catch not much of a yak
guy not much of a yak more of just a
size like you can't even though you're
covering me I have this incredible
wingspan I'm still gonna catch it it's
more that at this point of his career um
you've mentioned Kansas City last year
yeah that was week one though and they
threw out a lot of shocking things at
New England that they didn't have a
chance to break down I take all of that
into account I think it's gonna be an
awesome football game ten days to
prepare for Belichick exactly right ten
days to prepare for the best offense in
football and and I also look at it like
this I've heard this a lot and I know
you've already heard me say this to it
but I think everybody thinks like Oh New
England's gonna run the ball and try to
keep my homes that keep hearing people
say that it's gonna be the exact
opposite the exact opposite New England
is going to go on full attack shotgun no
huddle totally fluster Kansas City's
unsound defense and just got and they're
gonna go oh [ __ ] we don't know what's
coming we're just gonna play cover three
and sit here and Tom's just gonna go
five yards eight yards more yards so if
my home's like the Bronco is having to
put together one big drum right the
Patriots are gonna go you need to put
together three big drives to keep up
with us I think I think it's going to be
a back-and-forth football game I have a
hard time thinking that the patrons are
gonna slow down Kansas City a whole lot
either I really do but at the end of the
day with the extra time to prepare I
think that yeah old Billy ball game he's
gonna have a few wrinkles just to slow
down one or two drives to confuse the
young quarterback and because of that I
am putting $100 on the New England
Patriots and I am picking them to win
the game outright 34 to 28 in an awesome
football game that they come out on top
on you bet 500 on the Packers or the
Niners I gotta wait until Monday is
going on so you feel confident though
about the Patriots I mean no
I mean yeah you know and why did you say
the Chiefs on Sims and left go the show
and the Patriots now because the more I
just thought about the matchup well the
more you think about the Patriots game
the more you go at the Patriots it's
just like a human nature law and I think
the Patriots have had two good weeks of
offense Edelman's back in the fold I
think they're kind of finding out who
they are
I took 11 of course Kansas City's
defense is not special Justin Houston's
not gonna play like DOS that's just too
much for me to sit there and I and again
I think you know Kansas is gonna make
plenty of plays I just think like
there's gonna be a third and seven and
Patrick mom's gonna drop back once you
tries to go what the [ __ ] is this
coverage I don't even know what that I
really like is a Kansas City better
though that I get that half point yeah I
hear you I hear you
all right guys Monday Night Football
here last game of the week one in four
San Francisco on the road visiting the
two two and one Green Bay Packers high
of 46 in Green Bay on Monday night left
go give us the injuries Simms your
breakdown first there are no injuries
it's Monday night we don't know yet take
it away Simms okay
let me give you trends before ya go give
me your trans I'm pulling up a few and
they're our last 15 games as an underdog
of seven or more points the Niners are
115 they are seven eight against the
spread right but their own 15 right and
their last 12 months which who though
the how far that goes back the Niners
are 10 and 2 and 11 and one against the
spread San Francisco is one in four
against the spread this season and on
Monday Night Football Aaron Rodgers is
five and OH for and one against the
spread right it's pretty good
okay where did I start here
it seems going 500 on Kyle or Aaron so
it is a Sims quandary his favorite
quarterback and his favorite coach who
does he love more do I love more find
out now okay
the for the Packers offense hey we know
it's you know it's Aaron Rodgers but I
don't sit here and I'm not blown away by
the Packers offense especially the fact
that they can't really run the football
and that helps about 49ers defense to go
okay it's a little bit one-dimensional I
like to you always use this phrase they
can put more of their eggs in the Rogers
is going to
throw basket 49ers defense this year has
been pretty good as much as we wanted to
say hey I don't really like it other
than like the Kansas City game which was
just an early explosion they've been
pretty stout like the Vikings game there
was plenty opportunities Chargers drive
down they had a few goal line stance and
then one of the one of the scores on
that game for the Chargers was a
interception return that gave the
charges a short that's what happens in
all the Niners game I know it does
Arizona game all right in that 75 yard
touchdown by Rosen
there was no offense Arizona exactly
right I mean they scored a defense a
touchdown and set up the short field one
time for Arizona to score another
touchdown
so yeah the fear there is Beathard not
the defense the defense has actually
been impressed that is the fear the fear
is better and you know I look at Green
Bay and their defense is certainly
better than years past this is the best
run offense they're going to play this
or the best run office they played this
year and I look at that with their
ability to pass protect I just have a
hard time sitting here going Aaron
Rodgers and the Green Bay Packers are
gonna win by nine and a half more points
you know I think that when you look at
the Green Bay Packers um I'm just not
sure what they are exactly right I don't
know either
defense the same thing it's moments of
good but if there's moments of wow
they're just moving the ball down the
field on them at will whether it was the
Redskins or the Vikings in the fourth
quarter or you know I'm not even gonna
say the Lions last week because the
Lions got set up in some good field
position moments too but the bear is
week one the first half of the game that
was Mitchell risky's first game in a new
often so I don't have faith in the
Packers on defense all the way yet and I
think they're one-dimensional on offense
and I think that plays into the 49ers
hands and I'm betting $500 on the San
Francisco 49ers
[Music]
that is some horrible sauce so you did
500 on the Niners left go your breakdown
on this game I am putting $100 on the
Niners
[Music]
part of the reason and I can't believe
you didn't use this in your analysis oh
I should have said it if you don't know
what video I'm talking about a great
it's when Mike Patton was the head coach
of the Browns and Kyle Shannon was the
offensive coordinator and peten has no
idea what's going on on offense it goes
I think we should run it and Kyle goes
just looks at him like are you an idiot
like we're already running the ball at a
record rate this year Kyle is going to
know Mike Pettine
defense like the back of his hand yeah
he knows all of what he wants to do he
knows the weaknesses he knows what he
wants to take away and Kyle is sitting
back there look I'm just gonna be a real
man if you watching that Niners
Cardinals game Matt Breda looked like
Marshall Faulk
like in the first half of that game
before you got hurt the lanes were wide
open and we talked about how impressed
Arizona's been Green Bay is a smaller
attacking defense that tries to shoot
gaps and make big plays you know what
happens when a team was to make big
plays against Kyle oh [ __ ] tight end
slips out use checks slips out Kyle is
gonna be so ready for this game it's
going to be about two things can Aaron
Rodgers come come back and win the game
and a CJ Beathard going to throw this
game away nine and a half though is so
freakin much Jim I couldn't believe it
right I couldn't believe it and again
Josh who do I like to bet on baby
underdogs at home close the 49ers by the
way the games in Green Bay yeah I
[ __ ] love oh the seats on CJ Beathard
as an underdog yeah don't like him as a
favorite right love him as owner dog
he's got no pressure
yeah all right guys we got a wrap
one up so real quick I'm gonna go
through the disagreements there were a
lot of them left go we'll come to you
for quick locks gtlm bucks
making my move this week disagreements
Thursday Night Football Sims you have
the Eagles left go you have the Giants
moving on to Sunday Carolina at
Washington Sims you have Washington left
go you have Carolina jets and Colt Sims
you have the Jets left go you have the
Colts Cincinnati Pittsburgh Sims you
have the Bengals left go you have the
Steelers chargers Brown Sims you have
the chargers left go you have the Browns
Buffalo Houston Sims going with the
bills left go going with the Texans
bears at the dolphin Sims you have
Chicago left go you have Miami Denver
and the RAM Sims you have Denver left go
you have the Rams moving on here down
the afternoon games Jacksonville at
Dallas seems you went with the Jaguars
left go you went with the Cowboys Sunday
Night Football
Kansas City visiting New England Sims
you have the Patriots left go you have
the Chiefs left go who are you locking
this week I'm thinking about locking
Tampa Bay plus three and a half I'm
thinking about locking Seattle minus
three
I'm thinking about locking Pittsburgh
plus two and a half we don't agree on
anything and I'm not making my locks in
Minnesota and Houston this week I'm not
doing that
and I'm thinking about either going
Miami or Dallas Miami or Dallas Miami
against Chicago with the humidity and
then coming off of a body
it's a tough week out of your [ __ ] for
Dallas you are screwed yes I'll figure
this out all fair you're not getting it
on the pot all right
I mean picking five teams for guaranteed
to lose this tough you know what time it
is left go it's time for Simms to run a
catch train just about it is there's one
of me not going to have to run that's
yeah you guys are gonna make me run
every week like I'm going to break a
sweat now running to the train will set
you up with Joe you can have a meeting
yeah great
it's time for guaranteed to lose first
up Sims stop is chris is going to lose
and
lose his job at NBC because he'll be
late again on a Thursday so Sims is
guaranteed to lose first one the Rosen
one the Rosen one will be laying on his
back more than rising in this one
sorry Arizona your team stinks and
you're on the road against the Minnesota
Vikings who I think had finally found
them another rookie quarterback named
challenge if your name's Josh you're on
a team that stinks and Josh L and your
team your offense thinks I shall say
there's just not enough help against
this Houston Texas team you're on the
road you came off a win last week of the
Buffalo Bills that was a miracle no way
you do it two weeks in a row there could
be snow fallin and this team likely will
- oh this is a tough one but I gotta go
Denver Broncos you're gonna lose you
know why because the Rams are better
that's all I got for you they're the
Rams are the best team in football and
Denver finds a way to screw that game up
another team guaranteed to lose a team I
almost ha ha ha boys you are gonna lose
because a rope ain't gonna get it done
it gets a wild Jaguar they're gonna be
pissed off their defense is certainly
gonna be pissed off and that Dallas
offense is one-dimensional it'll be a
close one but the Jags got too many
studs for me and the last one the battle
between his best friend and his favorite
corner boy it's a tough one and my best
friend's a hell of a coach but damn he
ain't gonna win the football game he's
just gonna keep it real close cuz it's
all Aaron Rodgers and he'll find magic
somehow someway sorry 49er fans have
that wolves guaranteed to lose again
make sure you go to Costco where you can
get $17 off barbecue baby back ribs
all right Sims get out of here we'll
wrap it up without you alright that's it
guys you've been awesome thank you so
much again check out YouTube Sims and
left coast show we got to Rico with a
Bar Mitzvah a Bar Mitzvah me and Sims
showed our true colors I was an Eagles
fan he was a Giants fan
good luck to the birds tonight Giants
fans are losers you shouldn't hang out
with that sense it's out only 400
evening everybody and the lef koe man
Sims
good luck on this trade these hi guys
thanks